[Music]
oh
much better
all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and a lot
has happened in 2016 for better or for
worse we got a lot of new videos the
studio was born plenty has happened and
also a lot of smartphones are released
so this video will be your one-stop shop
for picking one of them this is for all
the people who ask me every time you see
me hey what phone should i get this
video is for you so for the smartphones
released in 2016 i'm going to be giving
you guys what's best in each category
and as i do with the smartphone awards
we'll give you guys a first place so the
best overall but also a second place a
runner-up also really good and then if
there are some honorable mentions we'll
also mention those in each category as
they deserve them so this is the
smartphone awards 2016. so the first up
category is the best big smartphone and
you guys know smartphones kind of get
bigger and bigger every year the average
phone size a couple years ago was
probably like 3.5 inch display now it's
probably up near four 4.5 inches maybe
even higher than that but these are
going to be the phones that are best at
taking advantage of being a big phone
the best that use a big battery that use
big displays big display features things
like that so my number one first pick is
going to be the samsung galaxy s7 edge
samsung has always been good about this
and a lot of the note features actually
this year trickled down into this larger
galaxy s variant so really this phone
shares a lot with the note if you don't
remember it shares the same exact camera
which is great it also has an excellent
really high resolution big display it
has a lot of those same software
features it doesn't have a stylus
obviously but it has the edge display
stuff as multitasking it has
multi-window apps so it really takes
good advantage of being big along with
hardware wise having a big battery so
galaxy s7 edge is your best big phone
but my second place is actually also
really good and it's the lg v20 i talked
about this earlier this year as being
one of the most underrated smartphones
not only is the main screen of this
phone pretty big at 5.7 inches but
there's also a second screen up top too
so lg figures hey if you're gonna make a
big phone you might as well use the
whole front of it and i'm still not
really sure about the placement of it
but i'm really happy that they kept that
second display thing going on and they
continue to evolve that and it's just
overall a giant piece of metal so if
you're into having a big phone these two
are your best picks now i have to give
an honorable mention of course to the
samsung galaxy note 7 moment of silence
for our fallen friend
but seriously this is one of the best
phones of the year this year note 7 had
a big display had a big battery had a
enough room inside for a stylus and it
had a ton of software features to take
advantage of being big it had huge
processing power it had a great camera
like i said but obviously we all know
how that went with the battery situation
and this phone exploding this was
honestly truly one of the best phones of
the year for 2016 but i can no longer
recommend anyone actually buy one or
keep one if you have one for your own
safety so note 7 was great but it can't
make any of these lists so next up
category is the best compact smartphone
it's the opposite of the best big phone
so as the trend continues as phones get
bigger and bigger it's harder and harder
to find a great high-end flagship small
phone the the flagship compact
smartphone is a really rare breed right
now but that being said it still does
exist there's not that many but these
are the best job at filling that gap my
number one pick is the iphone 7. this is
absolutely the best phone that apple
makes right now and the performance is
on point this is maybe the best
performer of any of these smartphones no
matter what their size with that new
chip it has great fast storage it has a
great fast camera the software is
excellently optimized so if you're into
ios obviously the iphone 7 is the
smaller of the two iphones and this is
one of the best ways you can go as far
as compact performance and then my
second place close runner up is google
pixel not google pixel xl obviously but
the pixel also is again the best of what
google makes right now it's a smaller
brother and it packs all of the same
exact features that the larger pixel xl
does you get the full punch with the
snapdragon 821 and all that ram and the
pure stock android the google assistant
all that put together here makes the
pixel a great experience again in a
pretty compact package but that's about
it i don't even have any more honorable
mentions that i would recommend even
close to those two for compact phones
released in 2016 that pack a big enough
flagship punch that's where it ends so
next up is best camera and i love this
category because among all the
smartphones on this table i can really
say that smartphone cameras have gotten
really good now i think the margin of
error i said this last year the margin
of error between the number one best
smartphone camera
and the number five or six best
smartphone camera is very small if you
pick almost any of the ones on this list
you're gonna have a good time that being
said my overall winner is the google
pixel and pixel xl for taking the best
photos of any smartphone camera this is
one of the most hyped cameras actually
of the year because the nexus line that
came before it didn't take the best
photos but thanks to the snapdragon 821
and hdr plus the new sensor takes
fantastic photos and it lives up to the
hype it takes great low light shots it
does a great job eliminating noise it
takes multiple exposures in the daylight
and has a fantastic dynamic range detail
and sharpness is there color is really
saturated and good to look at overall
photos from the pixel and pixel xl look
the best from i think just about any
smartphone that's out now my number two
pick for best camera in any smartphone
goes to the iphone 7 plus and i'm
picking the plus variant because it's
got the dual cameras but you could pick
obviously the iphone 7 as well but the
iphone 7 plus not only takes pretty
great photos great sharpness pretty
great detail and obviously very natural
colors but it takes i think in my
opinion the best video of any smartphone
on this table obviously it's taking 4k
video now and there's optical image
stabilization in both variants but video
is something the iphones do well and
have done very well for the past couple
years and the iphone 7 plus is no
exception plus it still has the best app
support for things like snapchat and
periscope and instagram stories the
iphone camera will do best with all
those and then i'm gonna give a third
place my honorable mention goes to the
galaxy s7 for being pretty damn good at
both at photos and videos it takes great
selfies as well very good wide-angle
front-facing camera but also it happens
to have some of the fastest autofocus in
any of the smartphones we see here again
pretty much any smartphone on this table
is going to take great photos and pretty
good videos but there you have the top
three so now next up we have a pretty
popular category the best budget
smartphones and i've said it before and
i'll say it again good smartphones are
getting cheap and cheap smartphones are
getting good there's a lot more budget
options this year and it's been a sort
of a trend and i'll explain exactly what
i mean by budget in a second but not
only do people not always want to get a
six seven hundred dollar flagship
smartphone sub size they want to get
them off contract but they also want
that experience to live up to those 6
700 phones these are the ones that do
the best job of that my number one pick
for best budget smartphone
is the oneplus 3t now this phone comes
in at a little over 400 bucks so 429
right now is the highest end of what i
consider budget there's much cheaper
smartphones out there but as far as
experience those this is a 100 a
flagship smartphone all the specs are
there obviously it's a snapdragon 821
there are six gigs of ram and then you
have a near stock android experience on
that pretty great five-inch 1080p
display and obviously the fingerprint
reader and the camera on the back 16
megapixels is pretty good the battery
life is pretty good and it has some of
the fastest charging in any smartphone
ever like if we're comparing it to cars
like this is your tesla model s this is
your fastest 0-60 time or 0-100 time i
might say of anyone on this table even
if you're not into that the oneplus 3
also came out this year about eight
months before that and it also has a
pretty low price even might be lower
than the 400 bucks now that it's older
and it still has great specs and a very
similar experience with that near stock
android my runner-up and this one got a
lot of hype earlier in the year is the
zte axon 7. it got a lot of hype for
actually having some of the best
speakers in any phone and it still has
some of the best speakers in any phone
i'm baffled all the time that i don't
see more stereo front-facing speaker
pairs htc was known for it zte picked it
right up where i left off and that
reason by itself is enough for it to
make this list it also has a near stock
android experience and has a lot of
hardware features people like so it's
pretty easy to go well there it has a
great low price tag and then my
honorable mentions are the alcatel idol
4s and the huawei mate 9. now the next
up category is best battery life this is
naturally going to shift towards the
bigger phones again because to have a
great battery life you need a big
battery but this this is for your power
user this is for the person who's in the
car like can i borrow the charger and
it's 10 am and they have like 20 battery
already this is for the heavy user who
uses their phone a lot and needs it to
last all day so if you are that person
the best option for you is the moto z
play now i have the regular moto z here
but the moto z play will be a little bit
of a thicker version of this they'll
have the same software on the front
it'll have a very similar display a
1080p display same great specs three
gigs of ram and it'll be rocking a
3510 milliamp hour battery and there's
something about what motorola has been
doing with battery that they won last
year and they're winning this year with
their phone again moto z play is getting
people like six hours of screen on time
which if you're an android person you
know how impressive that is so if you're
a heavy android user and you want
all-day battery life you can't go wrong
with moto z play now that being said
there's actually some other phones on
this list that come pretty close my
runner up here is the google pixel xl it
has a 3 450 milliamp hour battery which
is pretty close and it's the larger
version obviously over the regular pixel
but because of its pure stock android
and because of the optimization google's
put in with this pixel line you're also
getting five plus hours of screen on
time if you're a heavy android user
pixel xl is not gonna let you down
either i'm gonna give a third place in
this category as well because we're also
seeing pretty great battery life out of
the iphone 7 plus it has only a 2 900
milliamp hour battery but because of
again apple's optimization because how
well ios works with these chips it has
fantastic standby time so if you're one
of those people who can end the day at
50 battery you don't even have to worry
about charging overnight because you'll
probably wake up the next day with 50
battery so despite having that smaller
cell size the iphone tends to keep
making this list because of how well
it's optimized and also even honorable
mention to like i said the fastest
recharging phone that i've ever seen
with dash charging it's the oneplus 3
and the oneplus 3t it might not have the
biggest battery or the longest battery
life but the fact that it recharges so
quickly makes it a lot easier when
you're worrying about how long it'll
last also honorable mention galaxy s7
active that low key has a 4 000 milliamp
hour battery so if you're looking for a
durable phone with a long battery s7
active so next up is sort of a fun one
it's sort of shifted from last year
which was best design and we're just
gonna call it the best build the best
built phone released in 2016. and
believe it or not this one was kind of a
tie for me between two really great
phones but i'm gonna have to give first
place to the galaxy s7 edge it's just so
good it's so pretty again especially in
this gold one you can get a silver
variant the titanium is just so sleek
and it has so many features that people
like to see in high-end smartphones so
it's got removable storage it is
waterproof it's really shiny it's really
pretty it's got the angles it's got
metal bands all the way around it's just
such a well-built phone doesn't have a
usb type-c jack yet it does have a
headphone jack which is nice and also
the speakers are not the best again
probably because of the waterproofing
but overall this is gonna have to be
number one or a close sliver ahead of my
second pick which is the htc 10. the htc
10 is built like an absolute tank
it's got the great high end internals
but just looking around this phone the
unibody metal there is so much metal
here on the sides the big chamfer all
the way around and on the back so just
in terms of sheer industrial design the
htc 10 does not mess around it doesn't
pretend to be anything else it is a tank
in every sense of the word and it's
built super well so that's why it gets
its spot on this list and you probably
already know where i'm going with the
craziest design my honorable mention
goes to a phone i made a video all about
the design of and how much i love the
risk it took and that's the xiaomi me
mix the huge display
bezel-less phone from 2016. this one
made a statement i mean i loved making
this video just because i was raving
about how much i loved it it happens to
be maybe the slipperiest phone of all
time but it does come with a case if you
don't want to full time leave it exposed
like that but yeah the design of the
xiaomi mi mix has it easily in my
craziest design of the year now here's a
good one next category the most improved
award and this one's kind of a fun one
because i was tossing up again several
options for it but if you look back at
last year the bust of the year was the
htc a9
and i have to give the most improved
award to the htc 10 because they stepped
right back up to almost the heights that
they were at before i say almost because
obviously there's no boom sound they
still have a front-facing speaker and
they still have a lot of where they came
back but they have the high-end specs
again and they did a great job with the
software experience of making it not
only very similar to stock android but
having it really readily upgradable and
still including a bunch of features that
are over stock android and then there is
the bust of the year and surprisingly i
actually had like a couple candidates
for this one also it's 2016 weird things
happen now i think the obvious pick for
bust of the year just because of
phrasing
has to go to the galaxy note 7 who is
literally busting open batteries all
over the country and it's a weird bust
of the year because it was one of the
best phones of the entire year before it
started having problems if you saw the
review already you already know what
happened but it started catching fire
and then they started handing out
replacement note 7s to peoples who were
breaking they recalled the old ones then
the replacements started exploding too
so it's a dangerous phone you can't buy
it anymore bust of the year really
disappointing and it'll be interesting
to see what samsung does next year with
note 8. but here's another one to think
about
project aura
remember the videos we were looking at
for project aura of this modular
smartphone concept that we were
convinced was going to come to fruition
there was a whole team dedicated to it
had all these videos and people were
getting really hyped about being able to
put together their own smartphone with
all these pieces project r got really
lit for a second there and i guess now
they just killed the project i can't
even tell you why i'll leave a link
article below that sort of does a good
job of explaining the whole situation
but you can just uh scrap project aura
don't expect it anytime soon we saw the
modular thing happen a couple of times
we saw lg g5 which could also be
considered a bust of the year it's not
the worst thing that ever happened to lg
but it was kind of a weird experience
with that pulling out the battery thing
and not a whole lot of modules ever
happened with it and we also got moto z
not a bust of the year by any means but
another modular thing so i guess project
aura didn't completely fail on its
mission to promote this sort of a
modular concept
but the actual project is now dead so
that brings me to my overall mvp most
valuable phone it's my best phone of the
year and it's usually it tends to be the
phone that i use the most often during
the year
so that actually that criteria made it
really easy for me to pick for me the
mvp is the google pixel xl this might
not have been the prettiest phone in the
world it might not have been the best
look or feel in the hand it definitely
isn't especially from the ones on this
table
but the software experience more than
made up for that and that's why i keep
gravitating back towards near stock
android phones because the optimization
is great the battery life is great this
one turned out to have an excellent
camera and then just things just fly
along they're smooth the fingerprint
reader is smooth the home button is
smooth the assistant is smooth
everything the animations and frame
rates and gaming and performance and
multitasking are so smooth with pixel
and pixel xl i'm a big phone person i
went with xl but i also have two pockets
and my other pocket i pretty much always
have
my second place which is the iphone 7
plus even if it's just for its
performance this is one of the fastest
and most impressive phones of the year
in terms of internals ios obviously
optimization does great but i take a lot
of photos i take a lot of videos i share
a lot of stuff i go back and forth
between twitter and snapchat and
instagram and you guys know all the
links are below but these are the types
of things that make me carry two phones
because they're both so good now you're
probably noting marquez you haven't
reviewed the iphone 7 yet and yes you're
right i did my first impressions of this
phone and i did some other later videos
but i haven't done my full review but
i'll say still expect it it's not a
terrible idea right i'll probably do
something like a six months later uh
when this phone has been in my pocket
for a long time but obviously because of
its placement in this list you know that
i like it also i still think note 7
probably would have been one of my close
runner ups if they didn't start to
explode
but they did so you have it guys no
matter what you think of 2016 there
actually turned out to be a lot of
really good smartphone options a little
something for everyone you know if
you're a selfie taker or you take a lot
of photos or videos you got good cameras
if you need a long battery life you're a
power user you got big hands you want a
big phone or you got small hands you
want a small phone all kinds of
preferences were rewarded in some way
this year so that's been it maybe let me
know what your mvp is
most valuable phone best phone of 2016
in your opinion in the comments below
either way that's been it thanks for
watching i'll talk to you in the next
one
peace
[Music]